knowing what you know about war and the
teams if you could go back in time what
would you have done differently man I
wish I could go back in time Dave Burke
and I were doing an event earlier this
week and he was he said you know I'm
glad I'm not Ramadi
I know Lafe probably wish he wasn't
rowdy 100% i'ma go there right now let's
go and look it's what I would do
differently is the recognition that we
were super aggressive we took a lot of
risk what I would do differently is I
would actually be even more aggressive I
would be a hundred times more aggressive
I would be putting up you know a concept
of operations brief for your for your
approval to send up the chain to swim
across the river and hit targets and and
and you know put in some cyber over
watches and just completely ruin the bad
guys program going on in South Central
my when they had complete freedom
movement before they had any expectation
that we could be there before he might
get to us and I think they would never
see it coming which means that we would
have more impact and it would actually
be safer for us because they wouldn't be
expecting it so they were probably
hammers but we recognized that we could
get away with a lot more you know that
then we could and looking back on it I
just when you when you come into an area
in there like hey don't go in there
you're all gonna get killed you you want
to be cautious you don't know you don't
want to just jump into things you want
to mitigate risk and control certainly
but we recognize we could get away with
a lot more than we thought we could and
more often than not bring bring guys
home and of course that's the one thing
I would change obvious if I could change
if I would trade places with Mark Lee
and ride Joe in my platoon in a second
I'd trade places with Mike Monsour
indelible to it in a second and I don't
wish I could do that and I can't but
that is the that is what I would change
but I certainly would if we could go
back there again we would be even more
aggressive and we'd have even more
impact there's a term that that they
used to say and the teams I don't know
if you ever heard it you probably did
when we be doing special reconnaissance
training and guys would say trust your
camouflage did you ever hear that
expression
you may not have I don't want to listen
so what it was was when you got good at
putting your camouflage together you
could really get aggressive in getting
up and observing a target because if you
trust your camel if you've done a good
job with your kami paint your ghillie
suit and and putting yourself together
well the enemy is not gonna be able to
see you but it's really weird to be you
know 40 meters from a target that you're
looking at then there's a guy walking
around and you feel completely naked
like they can see but they can't see you
at all they can't see you at all and so
it takes some it takes some time to
learn to trust your camouflage and I
think you know obviously hindsight is
20/20 and when you look back at your
mati like you look back and you think
yourself what we could have done this we
could have done that we could have
gotten closer to that target we could
have done more things because our
hindsight's 20/20 and also we learned
over time to trust our camouflage and
the longer we were there the the more
aggressive you know operations took
place but yeah let's hindsight's 20/20
isn't it
that it is